Monday it was love between you and Josh
over the off season there's a lot of
rumors a lot of trade rumors a lot of
chatter you know this was a different
picture than what we saw from the last
time that we played last season do you
feel like there's any misconceptions or
anything that happened between you and
Joshua with off season yeah cause after
a 20 Game season your last image of me
and Josh was after the fourth down they
say a picture is worth a thousand words
so you can garnish whatever you want
from that image and create a narrative
behind it and it'll fit obviously
there's no football being played it's
just a lot of commentary he or C Shay so
for me I feel like uh the comments
conception was was that I wanted to
leave but it was like I never said that
it's just a tweet that said come and
rescue me I'm like damn like I thought I
thought we all listen to Drake at one
point you know what I'm saying it's
social media you know I'm saying you use
it how you want but at one point some
people dive too deep into things or take
it however they want to take it also say
I'm not responsible for how people react
to things I'm more so responsible on how
I carry and I'm just happy to have my
quarterback